I think that we kind of take for granted
the amount of knowledge and experience
that we have when we're heading out into
the back country
for us it might just kind of be your
regular Adventure but for others it's a
huge Endeavor and and scary and there's
a lot to learn
I can't believe that we just rolled in
here just before dark and found
a gorgeous campsite Wes you are in a
very good mood this morning this one on
the other hand this one
something no good
[Music]
ow
water's boiling honey
do you just want to do oatmeal this
morning yeah yeah it's oatmeal or no
meal in these parts
for Wesley's meals in the back country
because of his low muscle tone he isn't
able to chew efficiently so we puree all
of his food or give him as much soft
Mashable food as possible they can be a
little bit more challenging if we are
trying to live off the land as much as
possible foraging for foods and things
like that for him we do have to make
sure it's something that he's going to
be able to eat first of all and also
it's going to be easy on his tummy I
think Wesley is just responding so well
to being in nature but I think he's also
just happy to spend more quality time
with us but it just seems to be you know
more engaged with his surroundings don't
you less huh you little champ you're my
best bud yes you are
[Music]
so that was some pretty good feedback we
got from the physiotherapist about just
getting Wesley Outdoors totally and I
think it'll be a great thing to prepare
him for going to school because he's
starting school pretty much right well
I'm probably gonna cry when we drop him
off at school because our special little
boy you can't really communicate and
it's a big day for him he's gonna make
some friends he's going to learn you
know they have devices for him there
that we can't really fit in our house
but I think it's going to be great for
his development and for him to make some
friends
he's never really been away from us no
he hasn't no that long you know what I
mean your brother is going to go to
school and learn stuff as far as when we
one day live off grid unless we're
prepared to do some serious
homeschooling for him and Hudson yeah so
that's the other thing homeschooling is
a lot of work as well we'll find a way
to make it work you know yeah we'll find
a way to do both things when we first
started dating there was this
romanticized fantasy of living off-grid
in a log cabin in the middle of nowhere
which sounded beautiful but having
Wesley now and his needs I do worry
about living there full time I'm excited
about it I'm nervous I think that I'm
just more of the logistical person when
it comes to the kids
I don't want to be irresponsible with it
I don't want to be taking Wesley who
does have these complex needs so far
away from help
start I'm really looking forward to
having that off-grid property that we
can go to a couple times a year
and gradually make it home
Norris time to do dishes
[Music]